how's go rose my name is fool what the
[ __ ] my last boss so easy oh my god
a dying son of a [ __ ] looks like we're
gonna go inside this hole always been a
big fan of going down holes but but I
got champ a hit guys that's gonna copy
her she got hiccup to it sound like look
Oh goddamn it sob moon path mm Wow two
thousand souls to click a damn button
well at least my hiccup this guy America
would be me getting my two thousand
souls back Jessie Pierce strikes again
what oh hello
what the hell are you doing here Oh
sweetheart would you like some muffin
and cupcakes that's the same thing and
is that an MPC I thought champion or
Covenant was without it you want to come
up I got free salsa lessons up here I
swear they're free
why hello you don't like salsa we could
do tango I'm sound loudly as he really
doesn't like my dancing huh well the
game thought that was awesome so Bane 5
I've seen these gays trial ever but we
were banished are you ready no I'm not
where's the [ __ ] lever oh there it is
what are you doing here this is my stake
and only I can pull a I pull my stick
all day long baby
hah gay you're a goddamn perfect but but
but but I better break dance
hi the branch it's working lovely let's
go to this line baby
why do I never get invited to any of the
cool parties merciless the women who the
[ __ ] are you
eyelashes ah ciao oh hey not coming back
you want to dance outside a little
better this little bit of that
awesome I know I shouldn't have this
sword anymore but it's too good man look
double-double spike and a nipple slam
double-click anything I don't know I
need to find it by the one but it's
alright
drink piss time did he just teach me how
to brofist but i'll theist base game a
birthday I'm out of thing all I'm gonna
say is there better not be a boss in
here
I don't think at these
but Daris three Oh Martha Stewart what
are you doing here
oh she's dead now you're up next Justin
you will not get me Oprah Hey
that was the cake in the park and we
walking the baked cake cakey cake
what's that what's that supposed to be
easy or am I just that awesome
probably not awesome that's stupid
of wheelchair get out of our tariff
wagon-wheel
verbs my favorite are you a traveler
travel about collecting rare stones
which I never plan to visit it got
aboard I love my holes but this is not
one of them right okay it's better not
be a trap right if where do they all
come from
why get filled away
I got alright let's go in this be wary
of left oh thanks you were actually
right see that that's what I don't get I
don't understand we have Oh see that
[ __ ] damage welcome to champion
covenant [ __ ] I don't like this place
I don't like it one bit oh god what the
[ __ ] kind of atrocity I'm sorry you have
to die it has been said thou is ugly
thou must die not another [ __ ] boss
not another [ __ ] boss not another
[ __ ] boss not another [ __ ] boss
and a [ __ ] boss I'm not a [ __ ]
boss I'm not oh look it's your mom ha ha
ha maybe I can go up here now lit its
the baths with an infinite amount of
chance
god damn so many chins it has one chin
for every soul it has taken and my god
it has taken a lot of cells god damn it
I just want to rub it all over my naked
body god damn you're sexy
hi she was too hot I couldn't handle it
alright
it's time I'm sorry I'm sorry for
killing your mom
it's it's professed ha I swear hi we're
lost and I get back alright
new adventures I have a lot of [ __ ]
souls and I don't want to lose them baby
man fire chick binder in disguise man
fire I need to shave my thighs
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] damn
I even blocked it oh god piss let me dig
tez
I am so [ __ ] out of here I don't want
to lose these souls what am I even doing
I didn't shampoo with this morning god
dammit I wasn't supposed to tell anyone
yep see you later alligator hater [ __ ]
idle idle either not a lot man that
ladder I'm back with my axe it's
actually a club but it didn't rhyme so I
am back with my club to spank your butt
cheeks
don't resist actually like the club
smacking bros butts with it you want me
to smack yours
I know you do you dirty [ __ ] not another
boss not a lot about snot about a man
abandoned mad what the [ __ ] am I saying
teleport teleport don't touch me I'm
famous
goddamnit hey what is that your yeah bad
nasty girl
goddamn get a pedicure or something
really all the sauce poof
hello there chap - mm for a lie that
time some tough man I don't even know
why I made it but it's Gucci and I want
it oh that's pretty good actually
now I'm never gonna die again say hi
princess what are you doing on a loan by
a South hey Kevin
gotcha [ __ ] ha ha so I figured this out
all by myself and can did not tell me
about it the treadmill the treadmills on
fire the treadmill the treadmill that
why is it a treadmill the fight we don't
need a water let the [ __ ] burn
burn [ __ ] back to the game I
have a date to skate night god damn it I
love when where's your head at oh god
please don't give me I'm so sorry that
was inappropriate okay there's your head
I got it I got it now oh god no no I
don't want a hug
Oh God I'm alive so she's not that tough
actually the rotten blood needs to kill
me if he grabbed me I don't know if I'm
better or if I'm kitty er now's the time
that's my toss vinegar gamma [ __ ]
hey I didn't fight all this to die now
all right
come here come on love just want to poke
you that's all I wanted there you go
what's up give me a brofist what's up
bro fist and that's how it's done that's
how we do it in the booty pogchamp what
you lost or something
god damn tourists it's better be a
surprise party waiting for me upstairs
i'm gonna be seriously pissed they must
be hiding the birthday party in this
building in the next episode baby this
game is so easy i didn't even die once
in this episode
all right so next episode we will go to
my birthday party
it's not actually my birthday but live
like if you wind your watching at the
sky come bread today I'm itching my nose
and I'll see you tomorrow
lumpy breasts stay awesome